squid games is a brand new netflix movie
original whatever you want to call it
and of course somebody saw how popular
it was on netflix and so what did they
do they went and created a squid token
and this is the most epic rug poll that
we have seen in crypto in a very very
long time the idea behind squid token
was as a play to earn crypto project do
or based on the squid games that gained
popularity but we watched that token
rise 35 000
in just three days three days 35 000
it was like a rocket ship it went from
basically nothing to thousands of
dollars per token those tokens were
available for trading on all kinds of
decentralized exchanges like pancake
swap and dodo both based on binance
smart chain now according to coindesk
when you start to look at pancake swap
and dodo
to me
i think the names are hilarious
but there were several red flags on this
entire thing first grammatical and
spelling errors in the project's white
paper second the project's website was
registered less than a month ago and
users were having trouble selling tokens
on pancake swap so when you start to
look at this you start to ask yourself
am i really going to speculate am i
really going to invest
in a token that is based on a game but
the developers have no relationship to
that game and it is rising as quickly as
possible well of course some people are
they're greedy
they want to get the gains six
sick gains bro
well
as you can imagine the rug pull was more
epic than the run up
three days 35 000 percent the rug pull
took just seconds and so we've got first
a quote from the developers in their
telegram group someone who's trying to
hack our project these days not only the
twitter account at go go squid game but
also our smart contract we're trying to
protect it but the price is still
abnormal squid game dev does not want to
continue running the project as we are
depressed from the scammers and is
overwhelmed with stress we have to
remove all the restrictions and the
transaction rules the squid game squad
game will enter a new stage of community
autonomy just so happens that at the
same time that they got depressed
from the scammers
all the money disappeared
literally it just disappeared
immediately
look at that
massive run-up
that ladies and gentlemen is in a span
of hours the run-up between 6 a.m and 9
a.m and that is seconds where they
absolutely destroyed
all of the economic value if you go
ahead and you look at this tweet that we
have from charlie belillo he said
at 135 38 bucks 235 89
335 93 bucks 435 434
535 2800
people thought they were getting real
rich
540
i don't even know what that number is
that number is so low that i can't
pronounce it i literally don't know what
that number is but it's way lower than
the 2800 that it was five minutes
beforehand and so of course
in the crypto world there's all kinds of
crazy stuff going on we have a video
literally somebody was live streaming
the price
talking about it
while
the price went to zero and so we're
gonna play the video for you right here
and try not to laugh because this is
crazy
so the market cap is 2.168
trillion
dollars
and now the mark oh
oh it went to zero
[Applause]
live you just watched the rug poll
and so if you go ahead and you look
and say to yourself
why are people still putting their money
into these things if you went to
coinmarketcap it literally has a warning
at the top we have received multiple
reports that the website and socials are
no longer functional users are not able
to sell this token in pancake swap there
is growing
something diligence and exercise extreme
caution this project while clearly
inspired by the netflix show of the same
name is not affiliated with the show
and so what we need to remember here is
very simple you have to choose what
you're going to do there are plenty of
people who are going to tell you to go
invest in all kinds of nonsense we're
going to do the absolute best we can to
just show you
do you want to be a long-term investor
do you want to be somebody who when you
make investment decisions you go to
sleep at night and you don't worry about
what the price of some token is you make
decisions that literally you try to make
a better life for your kids or your
grandkids or do you want to be a gambler
do you want to go to the casino and
throw cash in there and hope more comes
back
i personally i don't have the emotional
control and frankly i don't have the
mental stability to go play these games
as the saying goes when you play stupid
games you win stupid prizes and so
please i cannot reiterate enough i saw
it in 2017. we're seeing it again now
stop investing in these crazy [ __ ] coins
please because what you are going to
realize is if you are doing it for
entertainment purposes you're not
investing you're doing for entertainment
purses go have a blast no problem
but if you are being convinced that
these are actually going to help you
build a life of wealth
happiness and financial security
you are being tricked
or you are being an idiot and somebody
needs to tell you
so when you see these come up if you
want to go do entertainment stuff knock
yourself out but i don't know a single
person that goes and puts 50 of their
portfolio or net worth
into something or purchases something
for entertainment purposes only
no intelligent person does that
and so if you buy
stupid things
sure some people will be able to get in
and out before it crashes
but if you buy stupid things over and
over and over again
you end up with
really really stupid prizes
which in this case means you lost all
your money